[Música]
se preguntaron cuánto tiempo de su vida
pasar yendo y viniendo a la oficina
ya está la cuenta sirven a 30 minutos de
su oficina y trabajan de los 20 a los 60
años más o menos 40 años son 13 meses de
su vida que vivieron en yendo y viniendo
a la oficina 13 meses
si hubiera 60 minutos de oficina son dos
años es increíble porque vamos a una
oficina entonces empecé a preguntar
porque como empresa solamente contrato
los registros de tengo una oficina pero
si nos remontamos un poco más atrás en
el tiempo vemos que durante la
revolución industrial hace 500 años las
personas empiezan a jugar el campo a las
ciudades porque están las fábricas ahí
hay trabajo pero no estamos más en esa
época las cosas cambiaron pero seguimos
teniendo ciudades innovar no es el mundo
que siguen creciendo hay más de 50 áreas
urbanas del mundo más de belleza
millones de personas no dejamos de ir a
las ciudades porque hay ahí trabajo
pero no tenemos ya cambio ahora tenemos
celulares tenemos internet tenemos mail
tenemos microsoft excel imagínense cómo
hacía la gente para trabajar sin excel
pero nos cambiamos la forma de trabajar
seguimos haciendo lo mismo que hacíamos
hace mucho tiempo y creo que en esta
nueva era era de la era de la
globalización tendríamos a empezar a
replantearnos cómo trabajamos y estas
cosas básicas y tenemos que ir a algún
lugar
hace 5 años logré algo por primera vez
en mi vida que me costó mucho trabajo y
mucho por hacer
en julio del año 2014 pude ver todos los
partidos del mundial de brasil de mi
casa
no es fácil son 64 partidos que no
requieren mucho esfuerzo
pero la razón por la que tuve hacer esto
es que ese mismo año empecé a trabajar
de forma remota para una empresa
era una empresa de 10 personas donde uno
de los fundadores del argentino bien
buenos aires
el otro argentino pero en eeuu
el primer empleador ha de córdoba y esto
de trabajar remoto se dio naturalmente
qué es trabajar remoto es cual trabajar
donde uno se siente cómodo puede ser de
la casa puede ser de un café puede ser
un oficina si la hay puede ser de otro
país en un bar que lo que uno le guste
la capacidad de poder hacer su trabajo
no depende de uno está
y a camisas muchos están pensando que
asiste eminencia al abrigo de necesario
yendo a cambiar lo que hacemos hace un
montón de años no quieren ni siquiera
trabajar no quieren ir al trabajo
esto no funciona claramente eran 10
personas solamente funciona se son
poquitos como me aseguro que la gente no
está en su casa mirando intrusos en vez
de estar trabajando
bueno por suerte en la empresa esta y
muchas otras veces trabajas y trabajamos
mucho y logramos crecer bastante hoy
esta es una empresa que tiene 500
personas en 30 países valen más de 1000
millones de dólares y es el quinto
correo argentino empresa que vale más
las funciones de dólares
lo interesante es también poco pensar
bueno esta es una excepción no un caso
que funciona no quiere decir que esto
funcione
pero lo que empezamos a ver es que están
apareciendo más de estas empresas hay
otras tres empresas que llegaron a esta
evaluación de mil millones de dólares y
ni siquiera tienen oficinas no hay donde
ir a trabajar si no me hiciera entonces
empezamos a ver que la tecnología se
está permitiendo que nosotros podamos
hacer esto no hay impedimentos y podemos
llevar al mundo grande pero mil millones
de dólares poco 500 personas
ahora si bajamos también quizás algo más
a lo cotidiano porque las empresas son
muchas cosas que no estamos
acostumbrados vemos que esto está
empezando a pasar y otro trabajo que
quizás no nos vino a preguntado antes y
poder hacer
un ejemplo muy interesante es el caso
muy amigo mío he contado el año 2014 se
lesionó la pierna y no pudiera trabajar
un mes al trabajo no pudiera sentir una
licencia y trabajado en la casa
quizás algún partido
pero es el mismo trabajar perfectamente
bien
llamaba a sus compañeros de trabajo a
sus clientes por teléfono
se conectaba a la red de empresa para
usar el excel y pudo hacer sus barcos de
forma normal
el problema terminó ese mes tuvo que
volver a ir a la oficina y ponerse
camisa pantalón de vestir
otro caso muy interesante es un caso de
otro amigo mío que hace psicólogo por el
cal
es normal pero acceso en vídeo
el psicólogo
y se comunicará si imagínense lo tan
íntimo es la relación con el ciclo y
poder hacerlo de forma remota
y otro ejemplo muy interesante del área
de la salud es lo que hacen las empresas
de medicina prepaga a disputarle dolía
la garganta llamamos un médico para que
venga a la casa y dijeron sí ahora lo
mandamos pero si quieren antes podemos
hacer una sesión con un médico por
videollamada para revisar a su esposa
obviamente dice que no
como para realizarlo en alargando una
persona con una cámara no se ve nada
fíjense sino probar alguna vez que hago
con la música la farmacia de boya
grandecita que miraba todo porque
obviamente ducha entonces hay muchas
cosas todavía que hay que terminar de
animar los detalles pero vean cómo las
empresas de medicina prepaga busca bajar
sus costos no tener que mandar a un
médico a la casa de todas las personas
que necesitar a alguien y al mismo
tiempo proveer una mejor atención al
cliente llegar más rápido
no tenemos que esperar las dos horas que
siempre tarda el médico morir a la casa
lo que quizás en diez puntos podemos
recibir una respuesta
entonces si nos ponemos a pensar el
trabajo remoto está apareciendo ya está
presente
y la pregunta vas a hacer porque no
sucede más porque no lo estamos haciendo
más
y la respuesta es que lo que falta son
culturas de confianza
no se cumplirá si la persona no está ahí
va a estar trabajando es así
pensamos que el empleado modelo es
aquella persona que trabaja de 918 viene
vendida por la particular la oficina
llegaba puntual actual hace sus tareas
el modelo del gestor es que se mueve al
cliente que controla lo que hace tiene
que controlar que la persona estoy
trabajando como controlo alguien que no
lo puedo ver es imposible
ahora pensemos en un gato
las grandes empresas todas estas cosas
las reuniones la gente va vestida de una
forma particular o vestida de traje no
confían en que te vas a vestir bien sólo
que te dicen que tener que poner encima
son todos iguales imagínense si van a
confiar en el balón o los atascos que
estás mirando puedes estar trabajando
odio que no ahora si empezamos a confiar
seguimos la forma de confiar abrimos un
abanico muy interesante de posibilidades
como empresa puedo ahorrar plata y no
tengo 29 físicas tan grandes puedo
contratar una mayor cantidad de lugares
nuestro restrictiva que la gente se
tenga que enterar un lugar físico pero
ahora una hora de su casa para poder ir
a trabajar y al mismo tiempo
la gente va a poder viajar menos va a
estar menos manchadas probablemente
producto un poco más entonces se abre un
par de beneficios muy interesantes y el
punto de vista de la persona que trabaja
en la empresa pasa lo mismo para el otro
lado no podemos trabajar es donde
queremos
en muchos casos podemos trabajar con
horarios flexibles y podemos trabajar en
la consulta que tiene esta confianza
como base y esto es muy importante
trabajar en un ambiente donde la gente
confía en mí estoy haciendo mi tarea que
podemos colaborar bien es muy valioso
mejora de calidad de vida a trabajar en
ambientación
finalmente para derribar como mitos hace
pocos haré un estudio de la escuela de
jose harvard que dice que la misma gente
trabajando de la casa y trabajando desde
la oficina es más productiva desde la
casa
y esa misma gente trabajamos por la
ritmo de la casa o cualquier otro lado
comparado con trabajar desde la casa en
más productiva de forma remota
entonces el mito de que si la persona no
está no va a producir es mentira está
demostrada en estudios que nos muestran
ahora cambia la pregunta esto sea lo que
funciona como hacemos para hacer lo que
nosotros hacemos 10 empieza por cómo
contratamos es lo más importante
además de hacer entrevistas a la gente
lo que hace entonces les mandamos un
ejercicio es una tarea para el hogar y
ahí vemos si la gente está cómoda
trabajando de forma remota no es para
todos
y también como si nosotros estamos
cómodos con las personas especialmente
vamos a ver miramos mucho es el tema de
la comunicación
se pueden comunicar bien se los entiende
cuando hablan por mail cuando hablar
escuchar porque esto que estamos
teniendo nosotros ahora que me están
viendo sus 300 movimientos por las manos
que me están escuchando a voluntad o
algo distinto no está cuando trabajamos
de forma remota en muchos casos entonces
que haya gente que se comunique bien es
fundamental para este tipo de trabajos
la contrapartida de eso es la
transparencia si nosotros podemos ser
transparentes mantener la información
disponible hacer que la gente pueda
acceder a la información que tiene que
poder acceder o cerrarla la gente va a
poder obtener el contexto para hacer su
trabajo bien si nosotros nos hacemos que
las cosas necesitan permiso que siempre
haya que preguntar si no hay material
para consultar es muy difícil aprender
cosas y el contexto para trabajar
y a diferencia de lo que estamos
mencionando antes el rol de los genes 3
deja de ser controlar pasa a ser
transmitir ese contexto para dónde vamos
y por qué queremos para esa dirección
del lado de la gente de quien entra es
muy importante la autonomía puede ser
que uno esté tratando hablar con alguien
que no está en su zona horaria puede ser
que esté tratando hablar con alguien y
no está necesariamente en el sitio la
respuesta entonces poder resolver tener
esa autonomía esa capacidad es muy muy
importante
finalmente no es que nosotros decimos
que el contacto cara a cara las
relaciones no sirven todo lo contrario
estima que ser remotos en lo que hacemos
el trabajo remoto para nosotros es
trabajo
pero una mejor acción todas las personas
de la empresa hoy quinientas nos
juntamos en algún lugar del mundo y nos
cómo volvemos a conocerlo ver como esa
persona utiliza sus gestos ese tono de
voz quizás esa frase en particular
podemos entablar esa relación para la
próxima vez que vengan me pidan algo lo
voy a tomar a la otra forma y es muy muy
interesante cómo se ve esa diferencia a
mí me pasó un par de veces y entraba
gente a la empresa no la conocía y me
pedía algo por chat
y las raras veces depende que esas las
palabras diferentes lo que uno está
acostumbrado pero cuando uno iba ya
conocía en persona esa misma línea la
ley es completamente otra forma
hacemos esto mismo aparte de todos por
equipo entonces todos los equipos una
vez por año se hacen exactamente lo
mismo pero una menor en hannah esas
entre seis días personas
ahora yo le estoy contamos todo esto
pero no quiero que vayan hoy mismo o
como decía el lunes y plantee quiero
digitalizar todos quiero cambiar mi
trabajo y tampoco pido que se pasen
directamente al industrial informática
pero quiero desafiarlos a pensar cómo
van a hacer para empezar a crear esta
escultura de confianza en donde ustedes
trabajan
como van a ser para trabajar un poco más
de forma remota y qué van a hacer con el
tiempo que van a dejar de perder en
horas de viaje muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]